I surely hope so.
I mean,
it's,
it's a,
it's inevitable that change will come.
Uh,
I hope it comes soon enough and,
uh,
and that the Cubans end up being free
enough because right now we're going to
see,
it'd be tough for them to just suddenly
be thrown into,
you know,
a whole new world that they don't know.
So was going to have to happen little by
little.
Uh,
but I do hope that they do that they do
experience freedom.
And that's when I would love to perform
there in a day where I don't have to ask
the government permission or have
anybody take repressive measures about
in any of our me,
against the audience,
against anyone.
And I would need that.
I would need them to be completely free.
It's happening.
It's gonna happen.
It's just for none of us.
It's soon enough,
but as long as it's in the best way for
them.